any time that you got into something
that was actually interesting you're
like okay parents grew up poor came from
a communist country mom grew up
uneducated somehow this kid's a
millionaire boring okay what do I need
to find I'm not here to [__]
degenerate
sales for his clients he made a bunch of
money on the internet boring well I'm
here to talk about interesting stuff I'm
not here to happen
yeah well no I'm here I want to and I
think what's interesting is that we talk
about the places where we conflict I
think it's great that you're an
immigrant and you came to America and
succeeded it's like oh okay great what
do you want me to do suck your dick yes
but it's uncontroversial why would I
want to discuss that tell me what is a
pleasant life with no attitude if you
know what an interesting conversation is
do you think an interesting conversation
until someone just sucking your dick and
doing a puff piece I think that is what
you think it is based on your podcast